es un hombre muy joven tiene apenas 37
años lleva 20 años haciendo política y
ha sido altamente cuestionado porque ha
desempeñado diferentes cargos dentro de
los gobiernos de los nacionalistas
escoceses y dicen las encuestas y los
expertos que con muy bajos méritos muy
pocos resultados para mostrar así que
por ello una de las primeras preguntas
que se le hacían cuando hoy se le ha
elegido como el nuevo ministro principal
de Escocia es como si tiene una hoja de
vida con resultados tampoco en política
va a cumplir las promesas que se
requieren en este momento para para no
solamente para las cosas sino para todo
el país como luchar contra la crisis en
el costo de vida y ha dicho que él va a
trabajar cada día para ello que es la
persona idónea para cumplir este cargo
Pero eso Por supuesto todos los ojos
están sobre él ahora sobre todo que se
ha comprometido con estas importantes
prioridades y una de ellas por supuesto
es la independencia de Escocia que para
el Partido Nacional escocés es sin duda
la más importante